(slow beat music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media,
and if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed,
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
- One of the things I love to
listen to is success stories.
You know, everyday entrepreneurs
who are making an impact
through the power of online video.
Today, I am joined by a
special guest, Mike Quist
of Stone Coat Countertops,
- Yes.
- And I am excited
because you are gonna be
one of the speakers this year
at our video marketing conference,
Grow With Video Live 2020.
- Thank you.
- We wanted to sit down
and just share the story
of how you got here, today,
and really give some
tips on what it's like
to be a video creator and an entrepreneur.
- Awesome.
- Thanks for being
on the podcast, today.
- I'm honored.
I am so excited to be here
with the famous Heather Torres.
(Heather laughing)
I know you're all jealous.
Yes.
- Yes, yes.
Well, Mike, you've been a part
of our Think Media community
for a few years, now.
- Yeah.
- It's been amazing to see this journey
and what this has looked like for you,
but for the people who are listening,
let's take it back.
- okay.
- Where did you start?
Tell us about your business,
and then we'll get into
some tips in a little bit.
- First, thank you so much
for being so genuine about...
You guys have cared since day one.
When you had no business caring,
you guys cared about my business,
so, thank you very much.
Our journey started really of me
trying to figure out how to
use video for my business.
You know, I'm a contractor,
I've swung a hammer my whole life,
I've built cabinets and
countertops, did granite,
and all kinds of different trades,
and I realize whenever I showed
my clients at a trade show,
I used to actually burn DVDs
of before and afters of my project,
because I knew if I left
that DVD with my client,
and I went home and typed up the bid,
if they had a chance to watch that DVD
before they got my bid,
I would close every sale,
because the power of video.
And then you translate that
a couple of years later,
and I'm creating
countertops with my product
that we helped formulate and
develop and invent over time,
and I go to these different
trade shows in my local market,
and people would see my product
and they'd want to know how to do it,
but I only wanted to do their jobs,
so I kind of hid it from them.
Then I realized I wanted
to start a training series,
because all these contractors who wanted
to learn what we did
and how we created it.
I said, you know what,
I'll teach them, but
they're gonna pay for it.
It took me forever to learn.
So, I built a series of videos on DVDs,
and I started to sell the series,
and people would ask and I'd say,
well, I'll give you the
series, but it's $2000.
And because my wife would
never let me sell it
for less than that.
She knew how hard I worked on it.
I actually sold one DVD
series in a couple of years.
I got so frustrated,
because I thought I'd sell a whole bunch.
So, I actually put all
my samples in a pile
and I said, I give up on this,
I'm not trying to go
down this road, anymore,
and I lit it on fire.
My wife was like, what are you doing?
We kept kinda going down that road
and I realized YouTube
was a great platform
because number one,
I didn't have to burn DVDs anymore.
I could literally upload
and then send a link
to a potential client,
and then I realized I was getting
a lot of inquiries from around the country
where I didn't work.
How can I get you to come do this for me?
And I'm going, I don't go to Wisconsin,
but maybe, I just didn't have an answer.
We started to really go down the road
to how do I get this
in a national platform?
How do I get my product
able to sell on a website?
I needed to learn about a website,
I needed to learn about cameras,
I needed to learn about
media and marketing,
which is how I found you guys.
I would actually jog on my treadmill,
I'd watch Sean's videos,
I'd watch you guys,
I'd then go apply that.
I would literally go up to my office
and apply what I just
learned in that video,
and it would move the
needle, it would work.
Realizing I had so much to learn,
I just watched and
consumed all that content,
and do you want me to tell
a story about calling Sean?
- Yes, sure!
- I hope I'm going down the right road,
but Sean, I'll tell you.
This is a pro tip for
everybody watching this.
If you're in a business
dealing with people,
which I think is every business,
- Yes.
- I had this grandiose idea that I wanted
to get Sean's advice
on new camera equipment
and I was going to fly
him out to our studio,
and he was going to teach me how
to use this camera equipment,
and I sent him this
long, thoughtful email,
and I said, hey, I'll bring
you out here to help me,
it'll be good for both our audiences,
and Sean was like, dude, I'm busy,
but I'll give you a few
minutes of time on the phone.
I was like, man, really?
Only a few minutes?
He actually set up the call, I called him,
and the amount of
information that I learned,
not in a few minutes,
because he ended up giving
me a lot longer that that,
'cause we kinda hit it off.
The information he gave
me made our business
over a million dollars.
- Wow.
- In a phone call.
- That was life-changing.
And so I was like, this
Sean from Think Media!
So then you guys had your first event,
- Yeah, Grow With Video Live.
- And I was like,
how many tickets can I get, you know?
- That's amazing.
So, you started this company,
you learned about online
video, YouTube specifically.
Now, you're not running a
small channel right now, Mike.
Go ahead and tell me about this process
of growing this YouTube channel,
and maybe some of the numbers and stats
that I know I'm excited
about to hear, right now.
- Oh, thank you for asking,
and I love bragging about it,
'cause it's our passion.
- Yes.
- You earn every bit of that growth.
You work so hard.
If you're a content
creator, it is a hustle.
I mean, yes, there's channels
that blow up overnight,
I don't know how,
but I know it's a grind, you better work.
Working really hard is what
successful people do, right?
- Yes.
- When I talked to Sean, back then,
I think we were probably
five or 10,000 subscribers.
Our channel is now 522,000 subscribers.
- Amazing.
- By your event,
we'll be at 600,000 or something.
- Amazing, let's talk about
some of the views, though,
that you're getting on
your channel, right now.
- I think we have 100 and
something million views,
I don't know how many
we have now, honestly.
It might even be a couple
hundred million views.
- Wow, that's amazing.
- It's a lot.
- Yeah,
because you're in a good niche,
- Yes.
- you are creating
great content,
we're gonna talk about that,
were gonna talk about some ways
that you can use video marketing,
we can help the audience with that,
but what's really exciting,
is that because of the exposure
that you've been able
to acquire from YouTube,
it goes just beyond YouTube.
You were able to do
something really exciting,
this last year.
- You talking about our event?
- No, I'm talking about you being able
to do something
- Oh, with our business.
- With your business, Mike.
- Yes, yes, thank you.
Sorry, I missed that ball.
- No, and an event!
You have an event.
- You threw me a softball.
Yes, the way that we really
moved our business forward,
is Catherine, my wife,
we built this business
off our dinner table,
we literally started at our dining table
and we quickly grew because
of our exposure on YouTube.
People saw me literally making countertops
in my front room in my house
because it was too cold in my shop,
and we had a fireplace in my house,
so it would stay warm,
and we would teach people these tricks
and tips of how we made something,
and the camera cut off my head,
I had my gut in the picture,
and the quality was awful,
but people liked it,
and I realized quickly if we
make better video content,
more people watch.
If more people watch,
more people buy my product.
So why not get better
at making better videos?
We worked really hard at
that, we quickly grew.
We now have over 30 employees,
we have a customer service department,
our own shipping department,
we source and ship all
of our own products.
We actually got noticed
by a national company,
one of the biggest chemical companies
that is specializing in polymers
and silicones and urethanes,
and we caught their attention,
because they were looking at teaming
with some of the best
companies in the world
at the things they were best at,
so they looked for some
of the best companies
in the world at Amazon,
they looked for them on YouTube,
we fit that niche in
YouTube for this company,
they got a hold of us.
I met them and I really didn't think
we would do anything with this company.
I just met them 'cause you
don't say no to a meeting
that you could learn something from.
So, I met him, and we actually
sold our business last year
for many millions of dollars.
It changed our life,
but I still work for that
company as their media guy.
We still make videos,
and I love this company,
and we're actually working
on so many exciting projects
because their eyes have been opened
to the power of video in
a product-based business.
- Man, that's amazing.
And you'll be speaking, like I said,
at Grow With Video Live
this year, as well,
which is why I wanted to have you on,
so people could see and hear who you are
and what you're all about.
In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a $1500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to thinkmarketingshow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Let's talk about some ways
that you have used video
marketing to grow your business.
Now, I know that you said already
that you were kind of afraid
to share your knowledge,
but really, you have lead
with education, first.
Let's talk about that and
a little bit more into
what made you shift in the types of videos
that you're creating.
- You know, it's the
whole crush it mentality
with give, give, give, give, and then ask.
I was asking before I would give,
and so I learned that hard lesson
of you got to give the information away
and then cross you're fingers and hope
that they support you.
Have confidence that your
product is what you say it is.
Be authentic about it, and if you are,
and people try it,
the internet's like a picket fence, now,
that people look over and give reviews,
and tell Sally what really
happens with your product,
so you have to be authentic.
We realized the better that we did that,
the more that the needle
moved because of YouTube.
So, YouTube was our
primary focus and still is,
because I like the fact that
I get re-marketing for free.
When somebody subscribes
and rings the bell,
the next time I have a
new video to show them,
they get notified.
Facebook is our second base,
we call him second string.
They're super effective.
I actually get a lower customer
acquisition on Facebook
than I do YouTube,
but the long term effects
of YouTube catch up
because of that re-marketing.
They are a good value,
but they're both such a
low-hanging fruit for us right now.
I would actually pay
too much for a customer
when my content was boring.
When my content wasn't educational enough,
I would actually lose money
advertising that video,
because not enough people were interested.
Even if you're gonna be a business,
first, you better learn
how to use the algorithm
the way it wants you to,
which is paid advertising.
When you have a video
that really kicks off,
here's a secret for your
audience, right now.
When you have a video
that really explodes,
it's gonna explode as a paid ad, too.
If it goes organic for us,
we put a little bit of money behind it
because we need more
eyeballs on that video,
and we capture new attention,
and then we learn how to use
the keywords and all that stuff.
- I love that,
so number one was educate,
number two, you just touched
that you were using YouTube,
are you using other platforms?
I know that a big part of
the video marketing strategy
that you had,
was to really stay focused.
Talk about what that looks like
with the platforms that
you're currently using.
- Yeah, if I tried to hit every platform,
I'm not going to be good at any of them.
So, we gear everything first to YouTube,
and then we realized the Facebook Lives,
when I go live, doing a demo, or on site,
for instance, at the conference we're at
right now, in Las Vegas,
I'm at World of Concrete,
we're doing live demos,
and we're going live on Facebook.
Let me tell you about that.
There's 70,000 attendees
at this conference.
A small percentage of them
are coming by my booth,
but when we go live,
maybe two or three hundred people
are gathering around our small booth.
You know how many views
we've gotten on those live?
We've gotten 140,000 views yesterday
on our Facebook Live videos.
And I can't get anybody on normal Facebook
to press Like or comment,
it's like pulling teeth.
You go live, why does the
algorithm reward me so much?
I don't know, but it moves the needle,
so I'm doing it.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so staying focused.
What about other platforms, right now?
I know that you talked about you want
to get into other platforms,
but what happens when that starts?
- You know, we...
I know Instagram's huge,
we post things on Instagram,
we call it our hygiene
content 'cause of you guys,
we call it our hero content
because of you guys.
We go hero content.
When we have hygiene content,
we post on it every single day,
but it's definitely
secondary or third place
to what really works, as soon as we...
You know, we're posting on Tik Tok,
we know right now Tik
Tok is low-hanging fruit,
but it's all kids.
But we know we need to
build our influence there
so that when it isn't
just kids, we're there.
We spend about 10% of our
time on the other platforms,
about 80%, 90% of our time
on YouTube and then Facebook.
- Amazing.
The last tip, which I particularly love,
because I'm a marketing junkie,
is that you're really focused
on what these videos are leading to.
They are free content,
but there's purpose behind
each video, talk about that.
- Yeah, we know that
we're gonna have a goal.
We decide that goal before we even...
Research before you record, right?
We figured, and I learned this
from watching you guys, too,
is if you pull people away
from YouTube all the time,
it's gonna hurt you, organically.
So, a lot of our video content
is in that circular batch.
I don't care where they
come in that circle,
but it's gonna lead to the next video,
lead to the next video.
I know that people watch
our videos for two weeks
before they visit my website.
When they visit my website,
I wanna keep them there,
but I've educated them so much on YouTube,
lead them to the next video,
maybe the same principles,
different color.
Just to show them,
pick your favorite
color out of this batch,
and then boom, I'll
bring them to my website.
If I always ask them come to my website,
you're gonna piss off YouTube.
- Yeah.
- So, we've learned
how to really take them
either to our website
or to the next video,
or if I'm doing something
with an influencer,
I'm taking them first and
foremost to that influencer.
Whenever we do a collab,
we want that to be about
the person, not us,
knowing that it will come back later.
So, we always have that goal in mind,
and then we've learned hardcore
the question of the day,
because of you guys.
It has to be a real question,
but it has to be a
question that generates...
I found that people want
their opinion heard,
so when you ask an opinion question like,
hey guys, do you like it
better before I tilted it,
or after, let us know.
Option one, before, show them.
Option two, after.
If you show them with text, ask them,
and then we actually,
I think we learned this
from you guys, too.
We type it out and boom, there it is.
It generates that comment.
When you do that, I swear right now,
that's making all the
difference in our videos
- Man, I love all these little tips
you're giving along the way.
And these are the type of things
that we're teaching at
Grow Your Video Live.
We're gonna go really in depth
in these type of tactics,
because we want business
owners to succeed.
Understanding how to make videos
is totally different than understanding
how to market those videos,
and so part of our mission
with Grow With Video Live
is to share both of those pieces.
- Awesome.
- I'm excited about that.
Last question, though, Mike.
You are a passionate business owner,
but you're a craftsman.
Talk about, just for the audience,
what it felt like getting into video.
I mean, of course you said
you were making video DVDs
of your products,
but I mean, you are a celebrity
in your industry, now.
You're getting invited to things,
you are speaking into different businesses
because of the impact that
the video marketing has had.
But talk about how that
felt as a business owner
who is a craftsman going
into video marketing.
- That's a great question.
You know, we get told a lot, now,
and I hope this doesn't
come across arrogant.
People say you're a natural, no, I'm not.
No, I'm not!
I was horrible.
I love how Sean shows
his videos, his first,
like, all right guys,
like, he's all...
- Yeah, that one.
- I'm like, man, I totally relate to that,
because what made me better was
having to edit my own videos
and going, shut up, man!
You're an idiot!
Yelling at myself because it was boring.
Because it was awful.
I worked really hard to get
better, and better, and better,
and now that we've worked so hard,
you get opportunities.
I read a quote one time that said,
it's better to be prepared
for an opportunity
and not get it,
then to get an opportunity
and not be prepared.
Because we worked really hard
to get better and better,
and literally, I invested
a lot of my time,
a lot of my money going and learning
from the people that I wanted to be like,
and from people who were
the best in their industry.
That's why we came out to you guys,
that's why I've reached out
to you guys like I have,
and you guys are so
good with your audience,
and so good with...
I can't imagine the amount
of inquiries you get,
so thank you, for listening,
and helping my small business,
which now, isn't so small anymore.
You're changing lives.
Guys, I'm not getting paid for this,
I literally can tell you
they changed my life.
They changed my business because I learned
how to take that information,
apply it in the ways that
worked for my business,
and then tested and see what happens.
- Wow.
Well, Mike, I'm excited for you to be
at Grow With Video Live
2020 here, in Las Vegas,
and right now, if you want
to claim your two tickets,
you can go to growwithvideolive.com,
but we have an amazing opportunity.
You can either win two tickets
by reviewing this podcast,
or if you want to get
started with what we did,
which was Video Ranking Academy,
which is what you're a part of,
you can get two tickets to
Grow With Video Live for free.
- What?
- Can you believe that?
That's right now,
so you can go and do that right now.
That is an offer that is only lasting
for a very short, limited time,
because free tickets are not free to us,
they are free to you.
- No, no.
- Thank you for being here today,
and I can't wait to see you in September.
- Keep crushing it, Heather, thank you.
- Yay!
- You got this.
- Thanks for checking out this episode,
we hope you got a ton of value,
and if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to
share it with a friend,
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(slow beat music)